à moukalla me papa me tiens bon jour il
fait beau aujourd'hui d'un mille aux
enfants n'est ce pas moi je suis content
heureux en pleine forme j'ai pris un
bain je me suis ni de l'eau de cologne
et je me trouve très jolie
si les vous qu'est ce qui se passe à
paris je vous en prie mais qu'est ce qui
vous arrive et qu'est-ce qui leur porte
qu'est ce qui se passe mais elle a fait
d'une de mes chaussures allées larges
zones d'australie oui je suis tombé dans
l'escalier de ma maison je me suis cassé
deux dents regarder ta force et ça c'est
pas bien joli mais c'est du snob a perdu
deux dents et il se trouve à fond alors
moi qui n'est pas dans du tout je dois
être horrible aussi joli mais il est
tout craché non mais vous imaginez mon
menée je vais comprendre le système ça
doit être terrible mais moi je n'ai pas
non plus hein
c'était affreux et aimant crâne tout
écorché j'ai perdu presque tous mes
frères c'est me repose plus de monde
alors là l'ami mais moi je n'ai pas un
seul se veut non plus alors moi c'en est
sans cheveux s'endort je dois être un
monstre
enfin ça me rend triste vous allez
monsieur juste là me suis dit stop faut
pas vous laisser aller tout ça ça va
s'arranger
une limonade ça va vous réconforte whaou
notre gentil vont me réconforter
beaucoup quittent limon à misrata ou
faire du bien mais c'est pas ton fait
pas julie je vais vous protéger je suis
casimir
qu'est ce qui dit il s'appelle casimir
ouais c'est moi me reconnaissais pas toi
qui casimir à casino ah bah oui c'est
casimir je reconnais savoir mais non mon
voeu que j'u mûre pour que tu fais tu le
lait mais vous avez dit tout à l'heure
comme monsieur du snob était affreux
sang dans son nez et sans cheveux alors
c'est pour ça que tu t'es vu ses
ouailles alors m'enfin ce qui est vrai
que monsieur noble et pas pour toi toi
dieu beaucoup plus beau sens dans son
nez et ses cheveux c'est vrai alors qu
ils pensent aussi françois mais oui je
le pense
chacun de nous est beau comme il est il
faut pas vouloir essayer de ressembler
aux autres ans
c'est vrai je prie qu'on parle je suis
comparé à celui qu'on tarde pauvre
monsieur du snav
tiens valérie prête moi ta raquette
voilà attention j'ai une idée
venez là monsieur du snob ouvrir grand
la bouche fêtera voilà et bien aaa
[Applaudissements]
mais je voulais enlever les quelques
dents qui restent à monsieur douchenov
pour qu'il soit aussi beau que moi
casimir t'as rien compris
[Musique]